well welcome veselin again to st. Louis
for another tournament for someone that
says that they either don't like we're
not very good at fast time controls you
seem to be playing a lot of them
recently have you been getting the hang
of it I'm not actually sure because
Paris and leuven was a bit disaster for
me and since then I didn't train that
match because also I had to play the
tournament here in San Luis sinco cup
and then in indy Olympiad so but again I
trained a bit and I try to you know to
improve my playing my blitz kills but
still I don't think I'm good enough
honestly you're not going to kill it
this time of the three plus two oh I'll
try I'll try I'll try but it also
depends very much on the moment momentum
everyone spare I think absolutely tell
us little bit about your future plans
after this tournament well I am playing
London then I blame Gibraltar and after
that it also depends if I if I get to
the new branches to then I also play
probably for some team for first time in
my life in the Bundesliga and now i'm
also starting a foundation to you know
forward to develop chess in bulgaria so
i'll be quite busy absolutely things
like you're going to be hectic with
other chess related but are not exactly
chess-playing projects oh yeah it's
completely different stuff